hey guys I'm back in this video we're gonna talk
about the six natural ways to lower cortisol
okay now what is cortisol cortisol is a really
important hormone that you really need a certain
amount of it but we don't need too much and we
don't need too little of it if it's too little
we're going to have inflammation a lot of immune
problems if it's too much we're gonna have a lot
of other additional issues including stress
states in the body blood sugar issues high
blood pressure a whole bunch of other things okay
but cortisol if it's too high is very destructive
on the body on the aging process it breaks down
your collagen it makes you look older so we want
to keep that we want to bring it down to a normal
level a lot of people have too much cortisol and
it interrupts their sleep so there's actually six
ways to do it naturally okay we're going to talk
about the first part right here where we're going
to decrease body stress do you realize that all
the stress that you've ever experienced is stuck
in your body to some degree so stress accumulates
your body is like a sponge and it holds stress
and what I'm going to show you in this next part
is several key things that you can do to extract
stress using an acupressure device that I created
so let me just go ahead and go right into it
and show you that right now check it out it's
very simple we take the widest part right here
and on your couch you lean back and you put this
right in the mid part of your neck sit back and
you let gravity push your head back into this
device and you just before you go to bed for two
minutes we're going to take the longer portion
and press it into some points in the abdomen about
an inch to the right of your belly button and then
we're going to press directly inwards like this
pressing in right like that and I'm going to hold
this pressure not so it's very painful but just
so this pressure for about maybe a minute or so
and its releasing stress if this takes the lot
of the flight-or-fight stress out of your body
also in your middle back that's the second part
that's where you're going to hold all the stress
to because the slider fight mechanism is located
in your mid-back and that's where you want to
work on a lot of stress also is contained in the
underneath on the top of the chest and the top
of the heart so that's another technique that
we want to do to extract stress to the upper
upper chest area and then the back of the upper
neck by the skull where it connects to the neck
that's another place where you hold stress okay
we're back to the second thing which is increasing
the quality of sleep that you have so we have the
quality of sleep and we have the quantity of sleep
we want to get to the root of it now in the last
section with reducing the body stress of course
that is going to help you sleep so stress could
stop you from sleeping but there's other causes
of sleep issues as well number one your bladder at
night you're peeing all night long that's because
you have insulin resistance or maybe a sleep apnea
and you have one of those machines that's a sinus
problem that you have or insulin resistance so
there's many different things maybe you're missing
nutrients okay but if you go through all these
things and apply some of this stuff you're going
to start sleeping better and it could be that you
just get up early and you don't let yourself go
to sleep so whatever you can do to enhance the
sleep do it even if you have to take naps that's
going to reduce cortisol very very important next
one increasing aerobic exercise I'm not talking
about the aerobic exercise that you would do I'm
talking about the type of exercise which is lots
of oxygen low stress and that would be walking
a mild version of yoga because they have Power
Yoga right now which is extremely exhausting I'm
talking about something that's going to create a
lot of relaxation I like the long walks will you
get a lot of space that will lower cortisol also
there's low intensity workouts like Pilates
very good for cortisol nutrient wise as far
as vitamins increasing b1 is the key vitamin
for your adrenals and stress b5 is also a key
B vitamin support the adrenals and recovery and
vitamin D as these vitamins go up cortisol will
go down okay number five herbal adaptogens you
can use ashwagandha there's a whole series of
that you can use I'll put them I'll put a link
down below of what I recommend but adaptogens
can actually lower our cortisol as well and
then increasing the parasympathetic nervous
system if you haven't watched my videos before
maybe you're not familiar with this word but the
parasympathetic nervous system is that nervous
system that is actively working to calm you down
it opposes the sympathetic nervous system which
is the flight of fight so it's in the background
chilling you out keeping things calm but when
you lose this heart rate goes up stress goes up
and you're in a state of flight-or-fight which is
stress so to support this of course all these are
going to do it and also potassium will do it
and magnesium will do it so you want to start
consuming more potassium magnesium you could do it
through electrolytes you can do it through greens
vegetables it just so happens that vegetables have
the highest amount and so if you're just eating
pure protein let's see during the Atkins diet and
you're not doing enough vegetables you're going to
get a lot of phosphorous and not enough minerals
to calm the nervous system down so you're going to
actually have hard time sleeping you're gonna be
more stress if you want to accelerate the nervous
system especially the flight-or-fight you want to
take phosphorous if you want to chill it out you
want to take potassium magnesium all right so go
ahead and apply these and put your comments below